yeah like when I came out of the film
we're all just like the humans are not
useless
that was the biggest thing really like
yo you gotta need the humans it's called
Transformers yeah it's not called rise
of the humans
[Music]
Anthony you're a 90s kid and it was a
90s kid you're from Brooklyn he's from
Brooklyn
how much of yourself was put into this
character a lot a lot I put a lot of
myself into it I mean the from the from
the street that I say we say no was from
I was from that Street Wilson Avenue
um you know uh I'm from the neighborhood
uh all of that you know all going all
the way down to talking to Steven about
what bridge in New York to shoot on I
was like y'all shoot on the Williamsburg
Bridge you know because that was the
bridge that I used to go over you know
where I live where I grew up you know
that was between Brooklyn and Manhattan
so yeah it's so much thank you
the last time I was book two was for
project power it was via Zoom it was
like 2020s I don't think you'll remember
me but like it's amazing to see you
thank you so much
um
yeah um what drew me to the role is um
her heart we all as as people we get an
opportunity like a calling in our lives
and some of us are brave enough in the
moment to take it and some of us uh are
not and I think that's what Elena faces
she is into her books and she really
cares about that and Her Imagination
runs wild but I don't think she takes
Adventure head-on and then the call
happens and she's brave enough to take
it and I was excited to just you know
there's very few people in the world
that get to say they met bumblebee or
Optimus Prime and there's only a small
number and uh we get to be those people
which is really magical it's Immaculate
if I do say so
thank you Anna told me it went from like
rapper to actor I like your first
freaking movie is like Transformers like
what the hell
um tell me about when you got to know
that you got the gig like how did it all
set up uh well it came through email for
us from Paramount and I thought it was a
lot I thought I had pranks going on in
my email but once I found out it wasn't
I was extremely excited and I was it
just I'm
informers movie Transformers rise of the
Beast let it rise
yeah I just thought it was incredible
and then once they told me I was
actually going to be able to come with
my uh entire family I was like oh okay
yeah
makeup trailer yeah
I was all set and like Paramount went
out of their way to
make sure that I was comfortable
throughout my entire first experience
and I don't think that's I think that's
I don't know if it's normal like that
y'all didn't get away moves to me but it
just seemed to have nothing I never I
never burned my family
it's not it's not normal but you're not
you're not normal
no I think when people think of
Transformers they think like robots but
what are some of the elements that are
really special to you about this film
in the way uh I mean just the story you
know and how there's no character that's
lost you know there's nobody in the
movie for no reason right everyone has a
reason everyone has you know whether
it's the smallest to the biggest right
but everybody is a part of the plot you
know so I think it took some time you
know I'm sure for Stephen and you know
the writers to figure that out but they
did you know and and I I love that you
know there's nothing is in this movie
for no reason yeah like when it came out
of the film we're all just like the
humans are not useless
you gotta need
to need Transformers
and then listening listening to the
audience and the fans you're like okay
cool like how do you make the humans
matter then like what are what is the
purpose then and we really really cared
about that